I think users are not cutting their spending,...
...they are just more mindful of how they spend.
And they are also unsure where they can spend on...
...when offline options are no longer available.
So, that's where we introduce what are new possibilities in this new norm.
So, it's all about helping users to shop smart in different ways.
That included getting more businesses online amid lockdown measures nationwide.
In a recent study, nine in 10 small and medium-sized businesses in Asia Pacific...
...said they are more reliant on technology due to the pandemic.
ShopBack, which earns a commission from its affiliate merchants...
...every time a sale is made,...
...added 500 new retailers between April and June,...
...expanding its list of 4,000 brands including Taobao, Amazon and Expedia.